if you're wake up in the morning you're
like man
i want to go
where there's just a bunch of young
hot
fit people that's not the beach
[Applause]
however if you want to say a couple of
times out loud not that bad of tits for
a dude that
that's your spot yeah yeah yeah if you
want to see some real meaty nipples you
go out to hollywood go out to that beach
man
yeah
one dude was pedaling his bike with his
titties just bat he's back she's back
yeah listen dude
i walked off that beach thinking
tell me again why women can't show their
boobs like you know what i mean they're
so much better looking than the ones i
saw out there today
and some dudes got him on the front and
the back and and
the ones on the back are probably a
little hairier than they should be uh
oh is that too far sorry
you're not the you're not the one who
had to see it all day
[Music]
there was one dude on the beach man this
is basically and by the way i mean i'm
here for this [ __ ]
look i'm i'm i
if you're asking me
at this point in my life would you
rather go to a beach
where there's just a bunch of good
looking people or would you rather go
see some weird [ __ ] i'd be like take me
to the weird [ __ ]
i've seen abs i've seen titties let me
see the dude today
who was making this noise
you know that noise up with his belly
button
take me to that [ __ ] beach all day
every day i was staring at him my wife
was like come on we gotta go i'm like
one more time i gotta watch him do it
one more time
yeah
i loved it
you know me i was almost like let me
smell that finger let me smell that one
time
you know what i'm saying
it's great people watching
it is great
people watching and also if you want to
hear a bunch of this hey oh
they're
i there were more new yorkers on that
beach i couldn't believe it
a lot of a oh hey oh
and you can tell the new yorkers because
you where are you from man you're from
virginia which is a little
south in new york right
and so you're used to the sun
the new yorkers
yo it's just a bunch of [ __ ] ripe
tomatoes out of that impeachment
and shiny like shiny
but we had a good time i like weird
24 day i'm living liquor just to make it
through another 24.
foreign
[Music]
another day another dollar howler 7 pm
what's it going to break another bug